why are they screaming they're not
screaming they're celebrating
hi I'm Mike Zimmer from ethics guide.com
for Wired Independence Day resurgence
picks up the action 20 years on from the
original roland emmerich blockbuster and
there are some epic shots and an epic
alien but to start with in this film our
heroes need to overcome a 3,000 mile
wide alien mothership to help with such
a vast undertaking roland emmerich used
a new end camp system on set to allow
him and the actors to see exactly what I
was going to look like when the
blue-screen was replaced with the VFX
well it's like actually something which
I really was looking forward to because
I heard about it like on already six
seven years ago and I used it a little
bit in a white house down to and then I
kind of made a decision to go for a big
you know like kind of crew there you
know because it's a little bit crew
inside intensive and and the interesting
part about it is if you know how to use
it it's like an incredible tool but a
lot of directors I have not the patience
you know quite to use it because you
have to kind of just it you have to kind
of always measure every lens in and
stuff so there's a lot of things you
know you have to kind of patience for
but I always have to patience and when
MN camera is not working I'm shooting
real fast something else and then go
back to to that what much has changed
the effects are bigger the ship is
bigger and the alien is bigger when we
discover that the hive is driven by one
mother of an alien
who is she
the film was supervised by Volker Engel
who has worked with Roland Emery on most
of his projects now while there are many
companies that contribute including
uncharted territory and scanline and
many others for the end alien bus
sequence it was in fact wetter digital
that Volker turned to led by Jolla Terry
and Matt akin he has the first time
you'd work with wetter yep first time
and I will work with them again and so
how didn't you how did you do that
process well it was first of all what we
did we kind of shot a lot of stuff on
the salt flats too and mainly as
reference so we knew exactly what like a
bus could do and we have a couple of
t-shirts in but not many because where I
couldn't convince this it's much better
to also create a bus in CG and then we
had like just I did storyboards and then
previous and then and then you know we
went from there and then they give a bad
luck whether it's a very unique company
because they make absolute creative you
know suggestions they said artists shot
we could do better when it would be like
this and then they show you how it could
be and then you say fantastic you've
always collaborated with your visual
effects chains and your art direction
here yeah sure but it's and sometimes
you know certain companies who who just
like only wants to do what you give them
and our stay you know they say well we
could do this better and that way or
better in this way if you thought that
in sequence looked pretty real in fact
almost all of it was CG where I came and
replaced live-action shots with fully CG
shots at a higher kind of rate and
they've done in almost any other film
recently one of the reasons for this is
they have this really great new exterior
lighting tool that lets them work out
very accurately what's happening in
exterior shots or contrast ratios and
and how the film would actually work
this of course then feeds into their
relatively new Manuka renderer on this
end sequence with the Queen the bass and
the attack on area 51 where the digital
did over 200
30 shots alone well don't forget to
subscribe for more behind the scenes
action
I might see more for wide it's
definitely bigger than the last one